a professor at the university of
maryland asked this awesomely evil test
question
you have the opportunity to earn extra
points for this exam select whether you
want two points or six points but there
is a small catch
if more than ten 10 of the class picks
six points then no one will get any
points
only i will see your selection it will
be anonymous to the rest of the class
do you pick two points or six points
when this question was posted to twitter
it went viral with a lot of people
discussing the question it looks like
there's a dilemma here
and a lot of people thought that look if
we at least picks two points if everyone
can cooperate then at least we can get
two
but that's not the game theory way to
think about this question so let's try
and analyze what the correct strategic
decision should be given the incentives
of this question
you want to think about your choice
relative to what the other people in the
class are doing and the relevant
characteristic is how many people are
picking six
it could be that more than ten percent
of the classes picking six
it could be the case that fewer than ten
percent of the class is picking six or
there's a small probability that maybe
exactly ten percent of the other people
are picking six
we'll construct a matrix based on what
the other people are doing
to see what your payoff will be
if more than 10 percent of the class is
picking six
then it doesn't matter whether you pick
two or six everyone is going to get zero
points
now if fewer than 10 percent of the
other people are picking six say
everyone else is picking two
then you are going to get the number of
points that you pick if you pick two
points you'll get two if you pick six
points you'll get six
and now you can see something very
interesting
you are always better off at least as
good off picking six as if you are
picking two
so picking six here is a logical choice
whether the class is more than ten
percent picking six or less than ten
percent picking six
you are always going to score more
points if you pick six versus two
now there's one third case to consider
is that maybe exactly ten percent pick
six
in this case you would get two if you
pick two
but you would ruin it for everyone and
get zero if you pick six you would
you know increase the threshold beyond
10
so in this one small scenario you're
actually better off picking two points
but it's kind of rare and there's no way
you could know that exactly 10 percent
of the class is picking six so in a
class of 10 that would be exactly one
person picking six and everyone else
picking two this is a very unlikely
scenario
so you can kind of disregard this third
possibility and you could say picking
six is a logical thing to do
but there's another reason to think
about why picking six is logical
exams are not usually based on the
absolute number of points you get it's
not usually a point threshold that
ninety percent is an a eighty percents
of b that's usually true in grade school
or high school but once you get to
college everything is usually graded on
a curve
your grade is based on how much better
you do relative to everyone else
so you don't want to think about the
absolute number of points you're getting
you want to think about how many more
points you're getting than other people
so when you think in this relativistic
method
if you get two and everyone else gets
two you're getting zero extra points
whereas if you get six and other people
get two then you have a chance to get
four extra points
so we want to reduce the payouts when
points are awarded by two
so if the class is getting more than ten
percent picking six no one's getting
points anyway
if fewer than ten percent are picking
six
then when you pick two if everyone gets
two
you're not getting any more points than
anyone else who's picking two
but if you get six and other people are
getting two you get four extra points
and then look at the third scenario
where exactly ten percent is picking six
so say one in ten
out of your ten percent class is picking
six
and one person's picking six everyone
else is picking two
now if you pick two then you're not
going to do any better than the people
who are picking two and if you pick six
and spoil it for everyone then you get
zero
so when you look at the payouts now
picking six is always at least as good
as picking two
so in this case picking six is the
logical choice and it's what's known as
a weekly dominant strategy so when you
have a weekly dominant strategy you're
going to want to play it
now the unfortunate outcome even though
everyone individually is thinking about
picking six and they all pick six you
end up in a situation that everyone ends
up with zero points but this is not
because any individual person is
thinking wrong this game is sort of
rigged so that the group outcome sort of
says oh you pick six you're selfish but
that's not really the case i think it
should be your decision to pick six and
that's the logical thing to do
thanks for watching this video
if you like more videos about game
theory and math please subscribe to my
channel
you can catch me on my blog mind your
decisions which you can follow on
facebook google plus and patreon you can
also catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books i've
written a book about game theory an
introduction to strategic thinking which
will help you understand this example
and many more ways to use math to
outsmart your opponents